[Musica]
questo è il manneken pis il bambino che
fa pipì
ok traduzione del tutto inutile me ne
rendo conto comunque si tratta di una
statua di circa 50 cm posizionata non
troppo distante dalla piazza centrale di
bruxelles
si raccontano stroia neanche
particolarmente fantasiose sulle origini
di questo di questo simbolo ma
certamente rappresenta un po lo spirito
scanzonato e irriverente degli abitanti
di quella città ma non è di questo
bambino che voglio parlarvi piuttosto di
un bambino in carne ed ossa che all'età
di nove mesi si trasferisce proprio in
questa città insieme a la sua famiglia
con quel flusso di carovane migratorie
che dal sud d'europa muovevano verso le
miniere di carbone dei paesi bassi lì il
bambino prese il suo imprinting
culturale
anche attraverso lo strumento più
potente che l'essere umano abbia
inventato che è il linguaggio
certo a casa lui tra le mure domestiche
parlava agevolmente italiano con tutti i
suoi parenti ma la lingua formale e
strutturale che imparava scritta e letta
era propriamente il francese e comincia
molto in fretta perché la madre aveva
l'ossessione che i suoi bambini
dovessero arrivare alla scuola primaria
sapendo già un pochino leggere scrivere
non che questo disturbo il bambino dir
la verità che nella scrittura trovò in
realtà una forma di espressione una
forma di rappresentazione della sua
dimensione attitudine artistica
il bambino scriveva continuamente dalla
mattina alla sera appena poteva e
scriveva storia fantasy le fantasiose
che raccoglieva in questo suo taccuino
rosso
tutti i giorni scrivendo tutte le sere
prima di andare a dormire storie
fantasiose e anche personaggi
particolari come il cappello parlante
molto prima di harry potter o come
l'anziana signora che aveva una seconda
bocca nel palmo della sua mano e tanti
altri
ma come spesso succede certi cicli della
vita si interrompono perché ne iniziano
degli altri
e fu così che i genitori del bambino
decisero di ritornare in italia
ma per il bambino non fu un viaggio di
ritorno per il bambino fu un viaggio di
andata lui stava lasciando tutte le cose
che avevo imparato ad amare fino a quel
momento tutto il suo mondo
è arrivato in italia dovette anche
sperimentare sulla sua carne come
un'abilità generatasi sviluppatasi in un
contesto in un altro possa diventare
paradossalmente un limite
sì perché lui questa lingua non riusciva
proprio a impararlo continua a
pasticciare con le doppie infilava
consonanti muti in fondo alle parole e
poi aveva ancora conservato quella era e
francese in un po bohemien ma che in
realtà lo rendeva un po lo zimbello
diciamo così della classe
e poi c'era una maestra
forse non proprio una brava maestra che
lo assillava continuamente sulla
necessità di ridurre suo divario
didattico nei confronti dei suoi dei
suoi compagni cosa che lo faceva sentire
molto insicuro ed escluso
succedeva una cosa particolarissima nel
bambino che più tentava di schiacciare
questa nuova lingua dentro la sua testa
è più la lingua originale sir attrattiva
sia mickey l'iva e in qualche modo
rimase orfano dello strumento di
relazione più potente che abbiamo a
disposizione non solo nei confronti
degli altri ma anche nei suoi confronti
nei confronti del suo talento
e fu così che il suo taccuino rosso si
chiuse e il bambino cominciò a scivolare
dentro una tetra malinconia
noi siamo fragili
la fragilità e la cifra della natura
umana
provate a pensarci noi siamo l'unica
animali in natura non aveva non avere
una specialità
non abbiamo un pelo lungo e folto per
resistere al freddo non abbiamo artigli
e zanne per cacciare in modo efficace
e non corriamo veloci come la maggior
parte dei predatori in natura nemmeno
usain bolt
e allora come possiamo potuti arrivare
sin qui che strano scherzo affatto la
natura come abbiamo come abbiamo preso
in giro l'evoluzione siamo un bluff
siamo un errore
per provare a rispondere a questa
domanda devo portarvi in un luogo molto
lontano in un tempo altrettanto lontano
chi vuole può anche chiudere gli occhi e
provare a seguirmi
siamo nella steppa africana 2 milioni e
400 mila anni fa un piccolo gruppo di
homo habilis e sta attraversando la
radura sotto un sole canicolare quando a
un certo punto un predatore si para loro
davanti e aggressivo e minaccioso fa
quello che deve fare un predatore in
natura quello che ha imparato a fare
cacciare per sopravvivere per il gruppo
di habilis questa è una tragedia ma una
tragedia conosciuta è già successo mille
volte qualcuno dovrà morire per qualcuno
perché qualcun altro possa scappare
sopravvivere ma forse questa volta non
andrà così
infatti il primo della fila quello più
esposto quello più vicino al predatore
decide di afferrare un bastone alla
terra ea cominciare a farlo volteggiare
in aria come una specie di ninja ante
litteram comincia a farlo volteggiare a
fendere l'aria e a saltare ad urlare e
addirittura pungolare l'animale sul naso
che ad un certo punto decide di
andarsene probabilmente più sgomento che
impaurito
a quel punto mi immagino che cosa può
essere successo
tutto il suo gruppo si è fatto attorno e
forse che una proto lingua non ancora
formata ha cominciato a chiedergli ma ma
come ti è venuto in mente di usare il
bastone non l'ha mai fatto nessuno ma
come è possibile
ma chi te lo ha insegnato e soprattutto
tu lo puoi insegnare a noi
io non so come può aver risposto questo
coraggioso
no questo coraggioso membro degli homo
habilis ma sono sicuro che da quel
giorno in poi nessuno e mai più uscito
senza il proprio bastone e sono
altrettanto sicuro che questa tecnica è
stata insegnata a tutti i bambini a
tutti i cuccioli che sono nati in quel
branco in quella comunità per molte
generazioni a venire
quello che il nostro coraggioso e
temerario homo habilis era riuscito a
fare è stato fare passare ad un next
level se stesso e l'intero suo gruppo
attraverso la modalità che è la nostra
effettiva specialità in natura cioè noi
apprendiamo noi apprendiamo
continuamente nel nostro rapporto con le
sfide anche estreme che ci vengono
incontro e che ci accerchiano e lo
facciamo
utilizzando gli strumenti che abbiamo
intorno e le relazioni
questo è il nostro nostra specialità
questa è la nostra dotazione evolutiva e
ce l'abbiamo tutti
ricordiamocelo è teniamolo qui per un
attimo
torniamo un attimo al nostro bambino
a quel tempo nella sua vita arrivo alla
musica e incomincio a prendere lezioni
di chitarra ma soprattutto nella sua
vita rivolgo un maestro c'è sempre
bisogno di un buon maestro
quel giorno però il bambino era
particolarmente distratto continuava a
sbagliare e non trovava la nota e
saltava delle battute e sbagliava le
chiuse sbagliava le aperture si
indispettiva sbuffava ricominciava
finché il maestro non lo fermò per
chiedergli se ci fosse qualcosa che lo
stesso e disturbando
il bambino non amava particolarmente
parlare preferiva a scrivere una volta è
però decise lo stesso di cominciare a
raccontarli quello che gli stava
capitando
e fu una valanga di parole e fu un fiume
di lacrime
dal canto suo il buon maestro non staccò
il contatto visivo nemmeno per un attimo
come a tenerlo avvolto in una specie di
abbraccio e aspettò
aspetto che ogni parola si esaurisse e
che ogni singhiozzo finisse solo a quel
punto il maestro fece la sua domanda e
di chiese ma tutti i ricordi che cosa ci
siamo detti la prima volta che ci siamo
visti circa il modo in cui si impara a
fare musica
il bambino al solo sguardo come se nel
cielo scoppiò fosse scoppiata una stelle
rispose una battuta alla volta ripetuta
mille volte
il maestro sorrise non ci fu più bisogno
di dire altro
quel giorno il bambino corse a casa che
sembrava un vento arrivo e trascinò la
sedia vicino al esigua libreria di
famiglia dove era sicuro che avrebbe
trovato una cosa importantissima è
letteralmente si arrampicò
girò con il suo ditino faticosamente
tutti i titoli del libro finché lo trovò
il vocabolario della lingua italiana
a quel punto lo aprì lo aprì a caso elin
cercò una parola altrettanto a caso e
cominciò a leggere la definizione ma era
difficile perché anche nella definizione
c'era parte erano parole a lui
sconosciute quindi decise di sedersi e
fare questa ricerca ampia cercò tutte le
parole di cui non conosceva il
significato una dopo l'altra finché
riusciti a ricomporre il significato
della prima parola
ed il bambino capi una cosa ebbe
un'intuizione preso una consapevolezza
che manterrà per tutto il resto della
sua vita
e che per definire una parola bisogna
convocarne tante altre e ognuna di
queste parole offre un pezzettino del
suo significato per definire la prima
parola questo voleva dire nella sua
testa nella sua mente che il linguaggio
che la lingua è sostanzialmente una
grande rete i cui nodi sono le parole
lui doveva solo avere voglia di
arrampicarsi su tutta questa rete
e così fece per settimane forse per mesi
i voti non migliorarono ha fatto ma il
professore che l'aveva detto e mai il
buon maestro e lo aveva detto che i voti
non sarebbero migliorati ma lui
continuava ad acquisire parole dopo
qualche mese aveva un vocabolario
quattro volte più denso di quello dei
suoi coetanei e ad un certo punto
comincio a sperimentare di scriverle
queste parole di accoppiarle fra di loro
e prendevano forma prendevano senso
erano effettivamente connesse e
cominciarono ad arrivare le prime frasi
i primi periodi
e infine le pagine è una sera il bambino
ri approccio taccuino rosso per scrivere
della storia di un ragazzo che doveva
uccidere un gigantesco drago
aiutato dal suo amico mago il buon
maestro che gli dava i consigli giusti
per poterlo fare
c'è una studiosa una psicologa americana
che si chiama carol dueck che dice che
la nostra mente funziona in modalità
binaria secondo due modalità fra loro
estremamente antagoniste la prima quella
che usiamo in larga parte nella nostra
vita e quella che lei chiama della
soluzione del problema
in questa modalità la mente va sempre la
ricerca di ciò che già conosce le
esperienze che hai già fatto delle
nozioni che hai delle sensazioni che
senti e le rielabora per poter
rispondere a quel problema contingente
ma poi ce n'è un'altra c'è un'altra
modalità che era caro al 2 è che chi ama
la mente che si espande la mente che
cresce in questo ambito
ciò che produce energia e la curiosità e
la mente non va al suo interno ma va al
suo esterno alla ricerca di tutto ciò
che ancora non sa di tutto ciò che
ancora non conosce
ora voglio provare a sintetizzare in due
punti quello che ci siamo detti fino
adesso il primo è che noi siamo esseri
per l'apprendimento
questa è la nostra dotazione
evolutiva ne siamo dotati tutti noi non
nasciamo nudi glabri incapaci di
muoversi incapaci di coordinarci eppure
la nostra mente già da molto tempo prima
si è attivata presa da questo afflato da
questo conatus no di voler acquisire
informazioni continue di apprendere il
secondo è che in alcuni momenti la vita
ci chiede di trasformarci in modo
radicale e noi non possiamo utilizzare
la modalità della mente che risolve i
problemi dobbiamo utilizzare la modalità
della mente che si espande
questo lo voglio dire anche a tutti
coloro che si occupano di educazione
diverso titolo
però infine chi non si occupa di
educazione
certamente un maestro un docente un
professore un pedagogista uno psicologo
ma anche un genitore un cugino una zia
un amico prima o poi la vita ci affida
l'esistenza di una persona che sta
attraversando un momento come questo e a
noi saremo chiamati a decidere se
vorremo essere più come la maestra o più
come il buon maestro
e che fine ha fatto questo bambino ma il
bambino è cresciuto non tantissimo non
può è cresciuto diciamo comunque è
diventato adulto
c'è un grande esperto dicono di
tematiche di lavoro è un docente
universitaria un formatore qualcuno dice
addirittura un consulente eclettico e
giuro che nessuno li ha mai pagati
ma certamente lui è un autore
e infatti quando qualcuno gli chiede ma
tu che cosa fai nella vita
lui risponde senza nessuna esitazione
io scrivo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì